ja ich habe die notizen wahrscheinlich
sei aber diese stegosaurus geil geil
hallo ich in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur jagd bleibt ja
aber erfolgreich ist aber heute ganz
ganz alleine nur ihren söhnen ist aber
jetzt auch vor allem mit der maus soll
dann stehen sie nicht wenig ich verstehe
ihn machen jetzt erst mal brennen
enthält weil ihn habe ich ja in meinem
kopf gekriegt
dafür brauche ich aber erstmal was
brauche ich denn dafür ich brauche ein
glas milch wo kriegt man milch von kühen
kriegen da krieg ich mir jetzt
vielleicht mal so freut uns vorstellen
wenigstens ja bist du so fast keiner
dabei habe ich ja schon gesagt keiner
die man irgendwie in dem verweis auf und
ja auf jeden fall und ich habe für diese
folge tatsächlich habe es geschafft
meine freunde ihr seht ich habe den
launcher komplette ich bin aufwendiger
und habe jetzt diese bugs nicht mehr ist
keine ganz normal aufnehmen und welche
bucks - die [ __ ] hingegen ihr [ __ ]
also ja warte ja kein wetter com auf der
leben klar wie ich brauche auf jeden
fall folgen messer und ein pulver in dem
pulver reiser erst mal das hängt doch
gar nicht zusammen am ort oder ich will
erst mal pulver bauen und möchte dadurch
ein pulver jetzt mal ohne spenden grad
wird ich kann ja nicht einfach mal
ausrasten fans gab mich am start weil
ich mir eben stiftes augen gesteckt habe
und ich darf deshalb nicht mitwetten der
zunächst jedoch die sonne geht ewig so
domain adressen herms fernseher alter
bei den leuten jan cat geil geil
ich hab ich lange nicht mehr aufgenommen
freut aber jetzt geht es klar ich nehm
nie wieder mitregieren tust du
karosserie tust du gar nicht du sagst
einfach jedes mal stimmt aber einfach
gar nicht mitgehen kann ich was mache
ich denn jetzt ja ich wollte fahren
wollen ist der ak was drin nein diese
leer geschossen scheiße wo sie um
himmlische anzubauen
himbeeren und bosch nein ich hab's dann
diesen hindurch als blog hier das keine
ahnung wie ich ganz eng dran baue ich
habe einen hut mich nicht richtig
erwischt es bei der bin dann bin ich
dann freund von spinnen nein die kräfte
dann bist du dich du bist ein kleiner
junge der von seinen eltern geschlagen
wurden kartoffel
wir wollen das nicht von die anfang mit
mir leid ist die freude dieser linien
die minis packen die sache nicht um eine
kiste machen das ist so traurig und das
ist auch richtig traurig dass ihr bruder
stefan voß auf die kiste drauf fixen das
gut sagt ach ich hab ich ja geht aber
nicht konnte habe ich bin konnte ich
habe das auf die kiste gemacht weil du
musst rechtsklick oder linksklick auf
die kids dann kommt ein komiker blitz
und ein glas gemacht gibt den tipp ja
nie wie gehe ich verkrampft erst hier
erst mit dem 4
kulak danke macht es nochmal ferstl
viert quasi zu mir ja nicht vergraben
und küsst mir den popo tätig war okay
ein bisschen an das kennt man von mir
gar nicht von galaxy an produktiv sein
bin ich ich bin er produktiv viele nicht
produktiv weißt du
wusstest der andere ich bring euch
plätzchen ich bin reich
weihnachtsplätzchen ja richtig tue ich
auch für deine mama bei deiner mutter
nämlich kein weihnachten feiern konnte
weil deine mutter nämlich über
weihnachten im ausland war es genau
guckt ihn nicht lukas aber bitte auf
mitzuspielen danke luca de maistre eben
nicht mit triviant ich sterbe ja gut
jedoch nicht schade war dass knapp er
war richtig klappt ist offen aber
gesehen schaut vorbei freunde ich bin
grad wieder richtig auf ich bin da viele
richtige lustig oder luca du hast wieder
ein bisschen nicht liegt ja nicht weil
ein bisschen minions machen oder doch
recht also ich hab ich habe schon
welchen farben luca ich würde mal dir du
wird also meine schuld daran ist er
macht lieber nicht das beste recht
einfach ja sonst wirkt mir nicht ich
brauche fossilien er bruder ich habe
einfach den größten himbeer busch der
ganzen welt hier angepflanzt hatte er
dafür den größten der den größten
blueberry bush wie hast du den er jetzt
an geplant er ist einfach richtig
kanalisiert aber ein haus der awo steht
einfach zu groß und wird aus wieso hast
du deine mutter in einer person
wie kann ich aus kanada wir töten wenn
die stadtpolitik nicht weil du dich aus
lockt dann nach unten dann sich von
selber weg denke ich doch ich weiß wer
die minions ja ich weiß das sagt der er
sagt einfach ich weiß dass du dich
vergraben nein tue ich nicht kategorisch
auf falsche abkommen schaufel und kann
dank sponsor dir sogar eine ich habe
auch keine arme penner finde das lustig
ja okay bis ich kann auch arme sponsern
ja geht mal welche aber 33 ich habe
meine das ist kann man das ende was du
hast ein kleiner computer wegs fuß
ich brauche jeden fall glas für dem
pulver ich habe mich echt vorbereitet
ich habe ein bisschen was im
singleplayer sogar schon gespielt und
möchte jetzt tatsächlich produktive
durchstarten
das problem ist nur dass klar ist wenn
man produktiv spielen möchte geht's
einfach nicht weil ich bin crafter immer
dazwischen redet man aber demnächst über
älter bist du wirklich ich mag luca mehr
als lukas der war jetzt echt also der
mich jetzt schon verletzt
du musst strom nemax gesehen hier lukas
es gibt dungeons oder den dungeons sind
batterien drin kein witz jetzt wenn die
batterien
du musst du musst halt du musst eine
spinne seien dafür da musst du die quasi
mit der spinne an lecken und dann
wirklich um den zaun und glaubt mir das
funktioniert ja inneren spaß jetzt haben
so nettig essen mit diesem busch um
einen gott alter das ist einfach sooo
geil da so richtig findet
aber wir machen jetzt diese wand hier
mensch ich bin konkret wie kann ich das
denn machen
wie macht ihr das freunde sagt ihm sagt
ihm bitte wie macht er das kann ich bin
ich habe richtig gute laune das galaxy
da bei mir läuft
schreib doch mal bitte in die kommentare
weltweit nutzen soll dankeschön
ich war selber entscheiden natürlich
kann ich selber entscheiden aber ganz
ehrlich luca wie die verizon wilster die
reste kommt da hinein du jetzt sagen ich
geh du hättest ja bitte auf wiedersehen
kleine fecker was mama ich hab sogar
erdbeeren alter ohne witz ich bin
richtig der farm bei glaube ich glaube
ich beschränke mich in diesem projekt
aus dieser farmen ja das ist so wenn ich
denke wie bei dem ich ohne chance mit
dem was einfach mal die super nanny
kommen halt deine fresse schule ist das
problemkind vom projekt das wissen alle
die spaß macht ganz ehrlich hip hop ist
gefährlich lukas passt mal lieber auf
der leben auf seine mutter ist dangerous
ich muss mal ganz kurz was sagen
fords wie kriege ich meine minions jetzt
zurück bitte was du musst damit also
willst dass die zu dir kommen
ich habe mir den masters darf ich die
ganze zeit auf dem boden die kommt
nichts auch wenn ich drücke ich mal
einfach strip andré fehlt wie vielen
arbeiten hast du nicht voll
du musst komplett verloren da musst du
rechts probleme bei der auswahl des
rechts oder links klickt wann kommen die
noch rechtzeitig mein haus nicht auf der
karte auf werden kirche kommt mich mal
besuchen
es gibt zwei verschiedene käufer aus
sehe ich gerade oder ja damit die von
thermen expansion von den anderen opec
werde auf die klamotte übergreifend
nutzen oder nein
die kommt trotzdem nicht
harris und drückt mal alt f4 wirklich
jetzt sind sie da er siehst du erwarte
ich mache es geht gar nicht älter
komisch sowas habe ich aber noch nie
gesehen
vielleicht ist eine missgeburt ja genau
genau das ist es das ist es das ist es
die mitte wo sind die denn ich habe
einfach einen pinsel gefunden und levi
teil auf ashes und bildung nicht immer
wo meine linien sind meine freunde hier
ist permafrostboden und eine ahnung wo
die sind so was soll ich da noch mal
dieser folge ich wollte fossilien mir
holen und mir dann einen dinosaurier
maschen
ich mache mir echt folge auch eines das
nicht cool zu bleiben
ich habe mich ausgelaugt und meinem
indien zwar noch drauf wie wasser was
tue ich hatte mich aus gelockt und dann
sind meinem initiale weg diese alle weg
dann ja wenn du dich aus wachs sind die
weg nein
doch
das nur bei dir so nein vielleicht weil
ich hab halt schon mal eine folge
aufgenommen siehst du das 100
das hängt das damit zusammen und wohl
auch das ja dann sind die weg gekriegt
ich hier gar nicht du kannst die neue
wieder beschwören mit dem stapler mit
dem mixstab der heiligkeit wo andere was
muss ich damit machen mit dem stab
restlichen morgen bei mir nicht die ngz
ich bin vergiftet ich bin ich habe ganz
richtig ich habe gerade ein
ich hab fossilien i hab ich wirklich
ja ich habe fossils galt habe ich zum
beispiel schon das bringt die zum
beispiel gar nichts ich habe auch schon
die knochen du penner ja was machst du
jetzt welche glocken hast du denn was
machst du jetzt was muss ich machen
werden damit wieder rechts links legte
auf die kiste beides gleichzeitig
kontowechsel hallo hallo baby was geht
er hat von euch irgendeiner ender perlen
wie kann man die vom server bahn
wieso hören du dich auf die höre ich auf
zu formen luca luka gleich wieder weg
beherzt aus wird älter hallo hallo ich
brauche noch mehr fossilien da kann
wieder achter kam drei bio fossils raus
wann die banken einfach am boden konnte
meine frage an der luft zu schweben in
kens diese wolken am himmel
sie ist heute ja die gitarre ich habe
voll gewundert letzte mal war einfach so
ein dinosaurier im himmel alter genau
diese wirklich in den wolken oben
wer den wein kann dass das war kein witz
diesen wirklichen krieg eine
faszinierende wolken und örtlich werden
oder nein über den schamlippen fordert
mehr wolken finden für meine familie
das halo wolken
ich finde das immer b ich finde aber
nasse habt ihr fossilien vielleicht aber
379 habt ihr viele kühe gibt doch ich
habe meine einmal nicht mit alter die
kurden mit konstanter santa claus is
coming to this is coming to your darm
was das denn ich hab' fans sie zum ein
gott geil alter geil auch im hardturm
was das da oben denn da steht einfach so
ein schwarzes dinge bist du das 379
vielleicht doch auch so dass eine wolke
weit weg wieder nach salzbergen oder
ganz ehrlich lukas interessiert mich
nicht so freunde jetzt noch ideen hier
komplett
und jetzt haben wir schon wieder einiges
an rohstoffen ich hoffe mal ich habe
doch die rohstoffe ich brauche ich hab
mich jetzt kopper was brauchen wir noch
für das pulver allerdings eine mama stil
glaube stil brauche auch die ganzen
minions von mir sind jetzt hoch gekommen
aber tun nix in die kiste das war da den
fehler hatte ich ja genau das gleiche
gen allerdings habe ich auch nie was
sagt dir brauche ich nicht viel stil
stil strohmann haus egal ob und trotzdem
einfach rechtsklick auf die machen und
dann verlieren die das ganze trägt diese
stil her freunde
hallo welches chlor das gefühl ich hab's
ferres oder heißt auch wirklich star ncm
zieht es ist rapper heißt es dein stil
wie heißt das ding an deine mutter ich
hab ne dino dna watson
wahrscheinlich sei aber diese des
stegosaurus geil geil geil dafür
ich hoffe meine folgen bewusst wird dann
ist wenn sie starb musste die irgendwie
so von der sektion dna die gene von den
viechern diese proben teile kriegst du
mit seinen kurvigen starb nach
rechtsklick auf die droge oder verlieren
die klar die bekommst du in dem du
fossilien in den analyzer passt dann ist
eine 25 prozentige chance zu einer dna
bekommst du die kanzlerin ausbrüten im
kälte walter mit milch produziert oder
du holst dir einfach her gut okay von
fossilien vielleicht von allem anderen
was da so mit diesem wirkstoff ja ich
will ja die darauf machen ließ berg
hatte man das mal gesagt da war der mega
op der fünf herzen mehr kann hat super
job super speed alles drauf aber ich
zeige seine dna scheiße ja ich hab das
auch zeigt es auch nicht richtig war
luca ist nämlich so ein bisschen mehr
die secret city haben das war alles
anders gefragt wollen das nicht so hier
zeigen weil das ist halt und für den
anderen gegenüber na ja keiner verstehen
wirklich schade ich hätte geweint ich
hab gesagt halt die schnauze lukas alter
ohne warum womit das cybermobbing ihr
alter es hier schon unsere volk über cmx
geworden ja aber ich hab noch nie
überzogen
ja ich auch nicht so klar dauert ich
will aber noch weitere folge aufnehmen
ok freunde ich war dieser folge warte
krass produktive machen dass man
maschinen locken dann können wir
aufhören macht der beiden verabschiedung
okay dennoch eine sekunde halt die
schnauze du machst bist du [ __ ] ganz
ehrlich winter reiches der nächsten
folge bei lukas dann bei mir geht es ein
bisschen weiter ganz ehrlich muss auf
jeden fall noch die mir nicht nach hause
bringen so billig ein zimmer im
fashionblog das war's noch einer von
galaxy meine freunde gebt den daumen
hoch wenn es euch gefällt dass ich jetzt
langsam an das hotpants oder stiegen
habe und weiß was ich hier machen muss
auf jeden fall bei lukas vorbei und auch
bei kontrasten kräfte und ja freunde
dann sehen wir die nächste folge mit
galaxy mit einem freund unterwegs
wiedersehen tschüs von j